[Música]
no solo huyen de la guerra también de la
crisis climática son imágenes de un
campamento desplazados internos en
baidoa la ciudad más grande del suroeste
de somalia
allí cinco temporadas consecutivas de
escasa lluvia han generado una intensa
sequía faduma alía dao perdió a uno de
sus hijos durante su desplazamiento a
Virgo
y de mi casa después de que la sequía
golpeara nuestra granja
perdimos todos nuestros animales
caminamos durante siete días y perdía
uno de mis hijos en el camino
en marzo la cifra desplazados internos
en somalia por la sequía y el conflicto
armado que vive el país alcanzó un nuevo
récord 3 millones 800.000 personas según
la organización internacional para las
migraciones muchos de los desplazados
aquí han sobrevivido a 30 años de guerra
civil entre el estado somalí grupos
Rebeldes y organizaciones
fundamentalistas
pero la destrucción de las cosechas
familiares y la muerte de ganado a causa
de la sequía han provocado un problema
mayor difíciles de soportar el hambre
en la sequía perdimos todo lo que
teníamos fincas y animales
uno de mis hijos murió de hambre y otros
están desnutridos
sin posibilidad de cultivar y con el
agravante de la violencia regresar a
casa no es una opción para estas
familias lideradas por mujeres la ONU
está trabajando con el gobierno para
brindar ayuda a los desplazados mediante
el suministro de agua potable y de
campamentos médicos como este mientras
tanto la crisis climática continúa y
según las agencias de ayuda
internacional podría generar el
desplazamiento de otros 300.000 somalíes
para el mes de julio